russia carrying out a vicious and
unforgiving new round of attacks and now
putin appears to be expanding his
assault to cut off parts of the country
for more let's go to bill hammer hey
greg how you doing good evening to you
enjoy the conversation here guys i want
to tell you what we think is happening
today
what we think the aims of the russian
military have been throughout the day
in the north it's pretty much a
stalemate pretty much frozen uh all the
action today has been in the south and i
want to show you a little bit as to why
mariopol is a critical town so is kirsan
i'll explain uh in a moment here you
know what crimea you know what happened
in 2014 when the russian invasion
happened there and they took that area
they also took the air in the don boss
over here but what they did not take was
this town of mariopol and mario pole
based on the reports we're getting has
just been hammered for 24 hours a day
for the past three days running
um it appears the town is surrounded now
why would that be well crimea was a
russian base
and they were able to fortify the
military there for the past eight years
and when the russians gave the ghost
signal they went right for mario pole
right here because
it is occupied by the ukrainians they
run the town it's largely russian
speaking however and a clear target on
behalf of putin and his army to try and
take this area what would they do next
where they're moving toward kirsan and
we we had a report that the mayor of
kirsan said the russians had taken the
city uh some other defense officials
suggesting that wasn't the case but
let's assume that is the case at the
moment why would that be important the
nipper river runs right down here and
kiersan sits right at the mouth of that
river and you'd be able to prevent any
traffic that went up or down and then
where would you go next the town of
odessa is here to the west and odessa
has a million people one of the top five
in population
for the entire country so here's the
strategy it appears pretty evident based
on the activity of today you got to rule
the south you got to cut off the
waterways and then perhaps once you
secure that area you can make a move
toward the middle of the country then
eventually up to the capital city of
kiev we believe the russian military is
advancing the red portion behind me but
for the most part it's pretty much
stalled out
and there has been significant heavy
fighting as well there's the capital
city you're talking about a distance
here
it's 16 20 miles give or take from uh
from kiev to the outskirts a lot of
people wondering about this this convoy
it's 40 miles long but what's it doing
it's been sitting there for days
why is that there have been a list of 10
different reasons to try and explain
this uh but to be honest with you no
clear reason as to why
it is here it started at the airport
then it just kind of runs up this road
here to a small town for 40 miles well
the center of the city is roughly
16 20 miles to the southeast
now
our pentagon believes that the strategy
on behalf of putin is still to take key
there's a big debate about this right
now but we believe
based on the reporting we've been
getting that the idea is to go ahead and
ring this city and then just smoke out
as many people in the military as you
can along the way and we have seen that
strategy already play out in multiple
cities
uh one of them is uh here in the
northeast
uh kharkiv that's that
you've seen the video right guys
it's just devastating stuff here if you
look at kharkiv on a map you just google
it you can see the ring
road that surrounds kharkiv it's not
exactly a circle but it's pretty close
to it and we believe that's where the
russians are
trying to clear out that town
in an ongoing effort and this is the
story that's only going to build by the
day you got a million refugees in poland
romania hungary and other parts across
uh eastern europe so that's what we
believe is the state of play is we try
and figure out all this stuff all right
bill stay right there we're going to
take it around for questions you know
it's funny i just occurred to me no one
knows how to explain the convoy could it
be a protest against coveted mandates
i don't know maybe we ought to say no
one's ever asked that question that's
why maybe if jessica's brilliant i'm
barely employable you could send canada
yeah break it up there you go that would
be a really good idea now i understand
yes what more have you learned hammer
about anything going on in regards to
the european countries the eu
you know i saw today that several of the
other countries are like moldova for
example have asked to join the eu
or they're looking to see if they could
join the west they want to be a part of
nato and i read this headline that said
as usual brussels is stymied and not
sure what to do i'm like guys
pay attention it's kind of like
northwest washington right right dana
when we were there i mean
greg you want to say about covert go to
washington d.c yeah they love it down
there let me ask dana all about it she
loves too
this is moldova right here pretty much
landlocked there is a section of this
country called
transnistria okay
in 1990 not to get too deep in the weeds
but you guys need to know this in 1990
it broke away from the uh the rest of
moldova it too
just like kirsan and just like crimea
and just like kharkiv and just like
maripo it is a russian-speaking section
of moldova so dana you could i mean you
you could see this movement you should
could see a connection here and that
would explain why the tiny landlocked
country of moldova is going to the eu
for cover and i guess they'll wait on
brussels for an answer on that for some
time
yeah because if you look at the map
there
you have those mountains
in romania the carpinthian mountains
there and so you'd want to carve out as
a buffer moldova
because
that cuts off any invasion corridor from
the south and russia would want to do
that so that makes perfect logical sense
to just keep going west there and secure
moldova
could be exactly right jesse
general waters it's uh and also he said
carpenter's general waters i tell you
jesse not to make light of your point um
that was not my intent there you go back
and listen to the video eight nine days
ago that putin released when the
invasion first started he he referenced
all this stuff going back two and three
hundred years that's what he's thinking
and i i can make an argument that
he went in car key for a reason he went
to marry a pool for a reason he went to
kirsan for a reason because in his head
he sees all these areas as russian and
that was the
that was the rationale that he used for
the invasion but i have to say
why is he parked a 40-mile convoy i
don't know that's there for days broken
the gas is running because you got to
have the heat on those guys have to eat
they have to go to the bathroom
a 40-mile convoy that's been parked for
days i mean they they have to be
deteriorating
why do you think that's the case geraldo
you know you know an 810 ward hog you
take out the whole thing in one one
afternoon i tell you bill you've read my
mind i
my dream is to have
in in world war ii when churchill was
begging for aircraft from the united
states before we entered the war uh we
they they contrived a device whereby
they would take the airplanes to the
border on the american side then use
horses to take them across to canada
where they uh and then they could fly
them from canada to the great britain
for the fight uh we should take a
warthog fly it to the
ukrainian border drink it above the
cross the line put the volunteer pilot
in it wipe out that 40-mile convoy it's
a sitting duck for those warthog a-10s
they'd wipe out that convoy in uh yeah
well i just had one thing that i know
you guys got to go but just add one
thing to that um the ukrainian military
had polish drones and they were very
effective in the first few days and last
weekend i think geraldo there was a lot
of um i would suggest optimism toward
the ukrainian military fighting back and
it was because those drones were so
effective
some will tell you some will suggest
that they've run out of their supply of
those drones i can't say that's the case
but that would help explain as to why
those trucks are still sitting there
largely intact exactly um bill it's
janine i have a question did you say
that the pentagon is is not convinced
that they want to take keeve i
um if i said that um
i would say there's an ongoing debate
in all military circles jeanine about
what what the objective is here
but leading defense sources earlier
today are still convinced uh that keeve
is a is a target on behalf of putin
he pretty much said it himself when he
was when he delivered his message from
moscow several hours ago
um
if there was a misstatement on that
jeanine i'll take it back no no you said
that there was disagreement but it
always
i think there's an open debate as to
what his intention is i mean a lot of
people think he just wants to divide the
country take the eastern half which i
mentioned is largely russian speaking in
many of these towns and leave the
western half of the ukrainian people to
go ahead and
if it is your desire to go ahead and
move and live in that side of the
country well then why
that's all why is it that macron said
after speaking with putin that the worst
is yet to come because that's what putin
said
that's what's what putin said right yeah
all right thanks bill great work on the
billboard got it guys hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else